You've made it.
You're just about at the end of
the course.
You probably feel proud of having
accomplished your goal and have rewarded
yourself with ice cream or a new
video game, well, that's what we did.
>> Anyway, inevitably you will have
questions while developing your million
dollar baby.
And you probably won't come back to
the course, so where should you go?
>> Our team of developers,
technically writers and
other awesome folks keep all the Google
maps API reference documentation,
walk-throughs, sample code and other
useful tips on our developers site.
We've linked to it a bunch of
times throughout the course, and
there's another URL in the notes below.
>> In the web area of the site,
you'll find most of
the information on the JavaScript API
that we presented in this course.
You can drill down into the Reference
section of the documentation for
each API to get the technical details
on all the classes, methods, and
objects we've used.
There's also plenty of sample
code you can view that
looks suspiciously similar to some of
the examples we've seen in the course.
>> In the Web Services section you can
see information on the services we've
demonstrated through HTTP requests.
You can drill down into each
individual service to get the details
on the request parameters and responses.
>> You can visit the Android and iOS
sections of the site to learn more about
incorporating the Goggle Maps APIs
into your native mobile applications.
Most of the features are similar
to those that we've covered for
JavaScript API in this course.
>> There is also a great FAQ, which
should be your first line of defense for
questions on the Google Maps APIs.
The FAQ also have a section on
understanding the terms of service,
quotas and usage limits and
identifiers, like API keys.
>> If you have a specific coding
question, we encourage all of our Maps
developers to use Stack Overflow to post
questions and contribute to solutions.
>> If you are, or are looking into
becoming a premium plan customer,
remember, some use cases require that,
there's a great online resource for
information on the premium plan.
This includes things like terms of use,
quotas and rates, support and SLA, and
tips and tricks for using your licence.
Finally, if you enjoyed this course,
there are some great channels for
more information on
the Google Maps APIs.
For example,
the Geo Developers blog, and
our Google developers YouTube channel
linked in the instructor notes.
>> Well, it's been a great journey, but
now I have to go back to New York and
get back to my real job.
Working with developers
using the Google Maps APIs.
>> And I have to go home to my new baby.
>> Luckily I mapped it and it'll
only take me 957 hours to walk home,
but I couldn't avoid ferries.
>> I think I'll probably
roller blade back home.
>> Thanks for taking the course.
>> And happy mapping.